I want my daughter and the rest of Mars
to grow up in a world that sees them and
affirms them and that gives them the
space to be able to show up as their
full selves to celebrate who they are as
young girls of color
[Music]
my name is an event martinez and i am
one of the cofounders of the radical
monarchs and my name is Lupita Martinez
and I'm a radical monarch the radical
Monarchs is a progressive scouting troop
for young girls of color the troops
mission is to create opportunities for
the girls to form a fierce sisterhood
celebrate their identities and
contribute radically to their
communities
[Music]
I launched a vertical monarchs in
December of 2014 because when Lupita was
in fourth grade she wanted to join a
local scouting troop it felt like the
traditional scouting group would it
really speak to her experience as a
young girl of color and as a girl that's
been raised with really radical politics
and so I had this idea what would it
look like to start a different kind of
troop where girls could earn badges but
the bad as they earned were based on
like social justice issues and topics
the monarchs earned badges for each unit
that they cover and each badge has an
activity out in the community like
participating in marches meeting with
legislators and talking with activists
who came before them
some of the badges that we've earned our
radical roots radical bodies and then
our newest one today which was radical
media for the radical healing badge we
learned about different ways of healing
healing with plans healing with herbs
and then for the black lives matter
badge we went to the mud Luther King
March the radical monarchs recently
started their second troop and hope to
expand to reach even more girls
[Music]
my vision and dream for the Monarchs is
that we have troops and chapters
wherever we're needed and wanted as it
is right now we get requests constantly
from all over the country all over the
world even especially in today's climate
I think that is needed now more than
ever
[Music]
you
[Music]